welcome to this video Yan
Bulman Yan Bulman yeah maybe that's his
real name you never
know let's play an open cilian and see
what he's doing the
con
okay this is one of the lines where you
can cannot really
play for very straightforward attack
with long castles you need to Castle
short let's see maybe I can
still get something going quickly with
F4
F5 yeah playing for direct
attack or E5 yeah well E5 is not going
to work quickly because E5 takes the
queen is on
D4 but in general this should be a
playable setup I still like to have the
pawn on C4 for increased central
control I wonder I
wonder F5 E5 Knight
E6 this is sometimes
possible wonder if this is such such a
case or is this totally
crazy
maybe F5 now F5 is more interesting
even
F5 F5 E5 Knight E6 takes takes and F6
hangs H come on I'm going for that
that's a fairly typical Motif
anyway let's
see
he's not taking
it
okay um
wow um okay I can take f8 if I
want but uh is there is there is there a
more aggressive way maybe Knight D5 yeah
there's still this issue with the
hanging Knight on Knight D5 E5 I mean
this is a huge comp compensation for the
piece I
mean quite
clearly if I get to install a Pawn on
E6 yeah and
now C takes or E takes I guess e takes
is
right yeah and after he takes
here this is going to be very
dangerous with the pawn on
E6 I can also take on G G6 this is
not not totally crazy as well but I was
really planning
this and now let's
see H taking on G6 is not
working but it's
close he might just take on he might
just take on E6 sacrificing it
back
yeah possible maybe I should go Rook F7
to to just
uh to just sort of clock up his
position ah hard to
play let's do that
I wasn't sure maybe I also should I
could have thought of just
preserving um just preserving my
Bishop yeah he's giving it
back
um
no he's got E4 okay I will take him at
least getting to equal
material uh
okay I haven't thought about that move
at
all Bishop
hangs uh Bishop B5 is not possible but
here I'm threatening Bishop A4
maybe and he can of course sacrifice the
queen
but this I'm not sure about with his
King position that that wide
open I think my queen will will be quite
good and I have the C6
idea
immediately
yeah Rook Bishop
D7 that's one
issue Queen G4 E6 may be
coming he has Bishop F6 Bishop D4 those
kind of
things
ah very tricky position not not not sure
at all what's going on
here this might be yeah yeah yeah this
is this is a very sorry very substantial
uh
play
okay I have to cover D4 I
believe
shouldn't allow Bishop D4
check sorry about
that now I'm going to take on A6 at the
end of this
line
D4 I have check on
C4 um yeah Queen
F1 threatening Bishop
D4 and threatening B4 H B5 I
mean
B5 to push him
back
uh very very
difficult you should go to D7 I
guess I I
also really want to get rid of his
um his
Bishop here yeah to go time Bishop
D4 Rook A2 Bishop
D4
to trade this and get control over the
dark
squares and I will enter here with the
queen yeah that's that's very difficult
to play for
him yeah the the bishop has no
squares
check
check check I'm happy to have the king
as an attacking
piece yeah I can I can I can mate him
maybe I can I could have taken as well
but it's it's a Checkmate now he has no
no check and I have Queen G7
made oh that was
tricky black
resigns that was tricky
really even
here the this this around here I mean
this P sacrifice was of course a bit
Yeah on this spec um spectacular I
cannot pronounce that it was uh yeah
wasn't like maybe um totally oh white
white wins says the comp okay Bishop C2
wins
okay yeah preserving this looks right
but I thought he will just re re re
sacrifice
ah ah okay well this is the big deal
yeah this I didn't see at all of
course um yeah and this is in fact very
strong of course I mean something like
this is check is killing him yeah okay
then Bishop C2 makes lots of sense
because the thing is if you look at this
let's say here and I go
here and now I'm starting to threaten
big sacrifices n C4 this this Knight has
no Square now this is this is totally
devastating and this is probably oh this
is also winning okay Queen G4
wins
because
this is killing
wow why
exactly because this
check leads to a
Checkmate
f8 C5 what is
C5
I don't understand it the comp is giving
C5 I don't I don't I'm not even vaguely
understanding the idea why not just
take King
d8 yeah okay well winning this is also
winning check okay so it really was an
interesting
sacrifice and here Queen F2 wins okay I
didn't see that
and now Bishop G5
wins yeah it's brutal brutal with the
comp this is even a a positional idea in
a way takes takes and now the light
squares will be deadly yeah this this
kind of things okay I didn't see that
Bishop D4 wins
okay um okay there were many many good
good
moves and
here I could have played the check on A4
intermediate check this is winning
now check I'm just basically a Tempo
up
okay and this isn't isn't that super
clear comp is always giving me a huge
Advantage but it it really wasn't that
easy and now this and Bishop D4 to have
at least the clear Edge yeah okay it
seems that um this should be okay yeah
all right I hope you liked it
complicated stuff and thanks for
watching